[Music]
today we're going to transform the data
that you have saved in fire store to a
fully fledged customer relationship
management system with air table
firebase is great for building apps but
it doesn't really have any opinion about
how you handle things on the business
side what if you need to visualize your
data or send a text message to a user
maybe you need to generate an invoice or
assign one of your new users to a sales
representative your table is kind of
like a build your own project management
tool that's a cross between an Excel
spreadsheet and a database in this
episode I'll show you how to integrate
it with fire store and cloud functions
and then talk about why you might want
to use this tool if you're new here make
sure to subscribe and grab the source
code from angular firebase com I've been
messing around with their table for the
last couple weeks and I've been super
impressed with it
and they don't pay me to say that I
learned about it from my friends over at
what's boots Switzerland
so a quick shout out to them let's start
by talking about what air table is and
why you might want to use it in the
first place
it's basically an Excel spreadsheet that
has a bunch of mini apps that you can
apply to your data we'll look
specifically at some of these mini apps
a little bit later but you would most
likely use this if you needed some
project management tools on top of your
firestore data so you wouldn't use this
to show end users but you would use it
internally as a project management tool
let's imagine you're building some kind
of software as a service application
with firestore you'll most likely want
to see our M in place so you can follow
up with leads and just make your
employees more productive you can get
started by signing up for an air table
account and it's free up to 1,200
records the first thing I want to do is
go into your dashboard and add a new
base there's a whole bunch of starter
templates but we're just going to start
out from scratch I'm going to call this
my customer base and I'll give it a beer
icon you can think of a base as a
context for your data or in other words
in Excel spreadsheet you can model your
data by adding various columns to the
spreadsheet you'll need to define all
the columns that you need before you
import it from firestore because it
can't just implicitly understand what
your data is beforehand you can see down
here at the bottom I have this add
random customer button which is just
adding a record to firestore with the
the script SDK for firebase air table
also uses real-time listeners so you
should see the UI updated automatically
as soon as your cloud function is
finished let's get this started by
running firebase and net functions then
I'll be using typescript but that part's
optional because this cloud function is
dead simple the next step is to CD into
the functions directory and then we'll
install the air table J s SDK just run
NPM install air table then we need to
generate an air table API key which we
can do under the account tab then we can
add it to the cloud functions
environment by running firebase
functions config set air table key
equals your API key now we can go into
index TS and write the easiest cloud
function of all time first we will
import air table and then initialize it
with the API key that we set in the
environment then every base has its own
unique ID which we can reference by
calling base with that ID which you can
find in the API Docs in air table in
fire store I have a collection of
customers and I want to update the air
table database whenever a new customer
is added we can listen to the on create
event on the customers collection then
we'll go ahead and set the data from
this document as a variable and use that
to update the base in air table a base
can have multiple sheets so you'll want
to reference the sheet which in this
case is customer data and then just call
create with the data that you want to
add and that's it now every time a new
customer is created in fire store you'll
also have access to that data in air
table run firebase deploy only functions
to put it to use in production that's
all the code we're going to write in
this lesson now we can move on to the
fun part which is messing around with
air table I have some data here in fire
store that's represented in a JSON like
object and if we go over to air table
you see it's more like a sequel database
table or Excel spreadsheet you can do
pretty much anything you would expect in
a spreadsheet for example highlighting
some rows and getting the sum or average
you can sort and filter rows but the
really cool thing is you can change the
view from a grid to something like a
calendar if you have a timestamp on your
records you can see everything in this
calendar view or you can put everything
in a gallery view which is a little bit
easier on the eyes or if you're a fan of
Trello or job
he's manufacturing you can put
everything in a Kanban view let's
imagine I hired a couple sales reps and
I wanted to assign customers to each rep
I can simply drag and drop them in here
and it will update that record in the
table these views are really nice for
organizing your data but I still haven't
showed you the coolest part yet which is
air table blocks a block is basically a
mini app that you can apply to your data
and it solves a lot of common use cases
with project management and things like
that let's go ahead and start by
visualizing some of the data that we
have in fire store in our table we're
keeping track of the users country as
well as their order total my goal is to
build out a chart that shows the order
total across all customers based on
their country of origin all we have to
do is come in here and set our country
as the x-axis and then that order total
as the y-axis and that gives us a nice
visual of the data that we can use for
internal report in you can customize as
many of these blocks as you want and
apply them to any base and air table
that means you can completely customize
your project workflow based on the needs
of your company in my case I have a Geo
coordinate for every customer so I might
want to visualize them with Google Maps
one nice thing about air table is that
it's tightly integrated with Google
cloud platform
so you can simply enable some api's and
use them an air table in this case we
want to enable the geocoding API and the
Google Maps API then we can simply go
into our firebase project and add the
API key from our web app config and copy
and paste it into the Google Maps config
in air table then I'm about to run into
a problem because I've saved my latitude
and longitude as just raw numbers and
firestore but Google Maps is going to
expect that in a format of a string with
the Latin long concatenated together so
how might we solved this problem I
definitely don't want to go back and
save more data in firestore so instead I
can set up a new field here in air table
but we'll use the formula data type
those who know excel should be very
familiar with spreadsheet formulas but
if not the idea here is that we can
combine multiple columns together based
on some code so in this case we just
want to concatenate two values together
with a comma in the middle when we click
Save it automatically updates all fields
in this row with the
our data format if we open up the map
block we can see that now all of our
customers are included on the map with
their actual geolocation coordinates we
can even click on a map pin and update
the customer record directly from the
map now another thing I get asked
frequently is how do i generate a PDF
from a cloud function well you can do
this programmatically in a cloud
function it might be easier to just do
it visually with the page designer block
and air table this little app is a
drag-and-drop page designer that has
access to all of the data in air table
so you can automatically generate a
standardized PDF for all of your
customer records or whatever else you
have saved in the table that can be
super handy if you need to send invoices
periodically or if you just have a
certain report that needs to go out to a
specific customer once you have your
template saved you can scroll through
and it will automatically generate a
different report for each customer
record another thing you might want to
see is the timeline of user signups in
your app maybe you initiated some kind
of marketing campaign and you want to
see the impact that had on user signups
with this block I've set up a timeline
based on the users sign up date visually
this is a lot more appealing than just
looking at the data in that basic
spreadsheet so that's pretty cool but
what if I'm a sales rep and I want to be
notified whenever a new customer signs
out there's a built-in chime event that
can notify you whenever a new record is
created in air table we can set it up to
play a sound and an animation whenever a
new record is added and then we'll bring
up our add random customer button here
and you can see that that plays every
time we click the button so I've just
shown you about four or five of the
different blocks that are available
there's 27 overall at the time of this
video if you're looking for an easy way
to get project management integrated
into your firebase project air table is
definitely an intriguing option I'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
if this video helped you please like and
subscribe if you want to learn more
advanced topics related to firebase and
cool api's like this consider becoming a
pro member at angular firebase com
you'll get access to a whole bunch of
exclusive content chat support free copy
of my book and a whole bunch more thanks
for watching and I'll talk to you soon